[Musica]
ho con me il figlio del Cipresso di San
Francesco e una un albero monumentale
che vive all'interno del convento di
Villa Verucchio vicino a Rimini si dice
sia stato piantato da San Francesco
800 più di 800 anni fa in effetti San
Francesco nel 1200 è passato dalla
Romagna mentre proveniva dalla Verna
Quindi significa che questo albero che
vi faccio vedere ha superato 800 anni
quindi 800 estati a autunno inverno e
primavera Quindi è chiaro che ha nel suo
DNA i geni della Resistenza alle
avversità climatiche e parassitarie Ma
questo albero ha di più come potete
vedere è una vera opera d'arte Anzi io
lo definisco un'opera d'arte di un
artista veramente straordinario forse
non voglio dire il migliore del mondo ma
probabilmente sì La natura Infatti
vediamo che ha una forma architettonica
nonostante dei suoi rami secchi la
corteccia screpolata e le sue ferite
Tutto questo ci fa capire quanto ha
dovuto combattere per arrivare fino a
noi noi dovremo prendere spunto da
questo per tirar fuori le energie che
abbiamo dentro per vincere le sfide
quotidiane
quindi questo albero è veramente un
monumento della natura
pensate che il suo figlioletto che ho
portato con me tre anni fa era alto solo
4 cm e tutto questo deriva e derivato da
un seme grande come la capocchia di uno
spillo quindi Provate a immaginare
Quanta energia quante informazioni erano
contenute dentro quel seme bene Noi oggi
abbiamo bisogno di conoscere il nostro
passato per capire meglio e affrontare
meglio il nostro futuro per questo
voglio raccontarvi cosa sono i
patriarchi della natura sono i
capostipiti dei nostri boschi e delle
nostre foreste che insieme formano i
polmoni della terra che ci permettono di
respirare
oggi sappiamo tutti anzi direi che
addirittura è di moda piantare alberi
Tutti vogliono piantare alberi ma non
basta dire piantiamo alberi dovremmo
dire quali alberi piantiamo dove Li
piantiamo come quando certo non in piena
estate è meglio molto meglio in inverno
anche se c'è l'impianto di irrigazione
ma soprattutto dobbiamo dire anche chi
se ne prende cura soprattutto nei primi
anni perché quando sono così piccoli lo
capite bene hanno ancora una radice
piccola che deve ancora penetrare in
profondità nel terreno hanno
effettivamente bisogno del nostro aiuto
ma quando sono partiti e sono andati a
fondo con le radici non hanno più
bisogno di noi anzi siamo noi che
abbiamo bisogno di loro perché noi senza
loro non viviamo loro senza noi vivono
benissimo
io definisco gli alberi in genere le
armature della terra ma in realtà i
patriarchi sono i pilastri fondamentali
di questa armature perché pensate quando
sono adulti i grandi alberi sono capaci
di arrivare oltre i 30 metri di
profondità per andare a prendere gli
elementi nutritivi l'acqua Ma sono anche
capaci di trattenere enormi masse di
terreno
garantendoci un assetto idrogeologico
del territorio tema oggi purtroppo di
moda abbiamo visto tutto quello che è
successo quindi sono fondamentali Anzi
per un Paese come l'Italia che è giovane
dal punto di vista geologico e anche
molto fragile Questi alberi diventano
estremamente importanti ogni albero che
perdiamo diventiamo tutti tutti più
poveri perché nessuna tecnologia ce lo
potrà ridare cosa facciamo noi
dell'Associazione patriarchi per
salvare questo patrimonio abbiamo fatto
tanto perché noi i soci fondatori dagli
anni 90 in poi è già un po' che ci
occupiamo di questo abbiamo censito
pensate a livello nazionale oltre 13.000
alberi di varie specie di sparsi sul
territorio dalle Isole dal nord al sud
Questo però è stata un'occasione
straordinaria per noi per conoscere a
fondo il nostro territorio la nostra
Italia vi assicuro che viviamo in un
paese veramente straordinario sotto vari
aspetti l'aspetto storico culturale
architettonico paesaggistico E
ovviamente anche ambientale Ma questo
questa ricchezza del nostro paesaggio
non è casuale è dovuta sicuramente e non
solo ai diversi ambienti pensate Noi
andiamo da un ambiente semi desertico
della Sicilia ad un ambiente Alpino del
Trentino Alto Adige con tutti ambienti
intermedi completamente diversi e quindi
possibilità di ospitare una biodiversità
Incredibile siamo Oltretutto il paese
più ricco di biodiversità a livello
europeo ma un'altra ricchezza
riconosciuta dai popoli che sono
arrivati in Italia pensate i Greci che
oltre 2000 anni fa sono venuti
soprattutto al sud Calabria Sicilia e
hanno portato dai loro paesi di origine
i prodotti migliori quindi i vitigni
antichi che ancora oggi noi coltiviamo
in Italia il greco di bianco il
mantonico laglianico Che significa
appunto ellenico il Corinto quindi i
vitigni straordinari che tra l'altro in
Italia è andato un prodotto migliore
rispetto al territorio d'origine non è
un caso che veniva chiamata Magna Grecia
bene quindi questa richiesta di
università È una ricchezza che abbiamo e
non dobbiamo assolutamente sprecare vi
dirò di più noi nella nostra indagine
non abbiamo solo cercato di censire
l'albero misurarlo fotografarlo e
archiviarlo abbiamo cercato anche di
raccogliere la cosiddetta memoria che il
grande valore aggiunto di Questi alberi
questo Pino loricato che vi sto facendo
vedere che mille anni e che vive sul
Pollino Intanto è una specie rarissima a
rischio di estinzione ma è anche un
albero che avendo mille anni a 1000 anni
di storia che sono scritte negli anelli
del legno Sta a noi saper leggere e
ovviamente Ovviamente poi farle
conoscere anche a un pubblico più vasto
Noi abbiamo realizzato una rete di
giardini dove Queste piante Poi le
abbiamo riprodotte messe a dimora
l'ultimo Tra l'altro di pochissimo fa
perché l'abbiamo praticamente completato
in occasione della festa dell'albero 21
novembre in quell'occasione questo
giardino è a San Marino si chiama il
giardino diffuso della biodiversità
addirittura un giardino che è dislocato
in vari luoghi del territorio San
marinese ma quello più come dire Più
unico più caratteristico Tra l'altro più
vicino a noi perché siamo a Cesena è
questo qui di Cesenatico la Cattedrale
delle foglie e delle piante contadine
qui credo che non c'è bisogno di parlare
Tanto voi immaginate sulla sabbia del
mare
200 metri dalla battigia quindi
dall'acqua salata vivono i figli dei
patriarchi più importanti della Romagna
Ma qui ci sono due opere straordinarie
l'opera cattedrale delle foglie sette
foglie in acciaio corten disposte ad
anfiteatro proprio per ricordare una
cattedrale opera di un grandissimo
personaggio che ha fatto tanto per la
Romagna Tonino Guerra che ha lavorato
con tutti i più grandi registi Fellini
ma Antonioni e soprattutto anche registi
stranieri bene questa è un'opera
dell'uomo a fianco di questo ci sono le
piante contadine opera Come dicevamo
prima della natura qui però c'è un
albero molto particolare che lo vedete
Fiorito nell'immagine più piccola che è
un mandorlo ma ha una storia incredibile
e mi fa molto piacere a raccontarvelo
quando Tonino nel 2012 ci ha lasciato
perché è andato nella sua stanza come
diceva lui e io ho voluto fare un
piccolo omaggio per Tonino che ha fatto
tanto per noi anche per la nostra
associazione
ho preso un ramo dal mandorlo del suo
giardino presso la casa dei Mandorli di
Pennabilli l'ho riprodotto e ho fatto
questa piantina che ho messo a dimora
all'anno successivo lì a Cesenatico oggi
vedete Questa pianta addirittura va in
piena fioritura pensate che fiorisce
proprio primavera quando Tonino ci ha
lasciati il 21 marzo Tra l'altro il
primo giorno di primavera quindi oggi io
quell'albero non lo chiamo mandorlo ma
lo chiamo il respiro di Tonino perché
Tonino stava seduto sotto quel mandorlo
e la sua anidride carbonica Siccome gli
alberi si cibano di anidride carbonica è
finita in quel legno Quindi io posso
benissimo chiamarlo il respiro di Tonino
e mi sembra un pensiero molto come dire
riconoscente per una persona che ha
fatto tantissimo per il mondo intero per
il mondo del cinema oggi è definito
veramente un gigante
noi suddividiamo la nostra indagine in
due grandi settori i patriarchi della
natura che sono i capostipiti dei Boschi
delle foreste quindi piante forestali e
li riproduciamo li moltiplichiamo perché
abbiamo capito che i figli di Questi
alberi sono sicuramente gli alberi più
importanti per il nostro futuro perché
se io dovessi ricostruire un bosco a
seguito di un incendio oppure
consolidare un'area dove c'è un terreno
degradato a rischio frane io non vado a
comprare le piante dall'estero perché
magari costano meno con il rischio di
mettere di nuovo a piante che non sono
acclimate quindi vivranno malissimo e in
più posso portare pure malattie se io
pianto i figli di questi Questi alberi
qua o maggiori garanzie non solo di
longevità ma anche di adattamento Queste
piante sono adattate quindi partono
subito e gli apparati radicali vanno in
profondità e fanno quell'azione
importante che dicevamo prima l'altro
grande altro settore di cui noi ci
occupiamo è quello ti patriarchi da
frutto cioè i capostipiti della
frutticoltura pensate che la nostra
regione e Cesena neon è un validissimo
esempio era capitale europea della
frutticoltura qui è nata addirittura la
frutticoltura e qui ha fatto la fortuna
di tanti Agricoltori Cesenatico
quello di fianco il nocciolo dell'aria
sempre più vicino a noi siamo Sogliano
Rubicone è una pianta di interesse
europeo voi Immagino che sappiate i
noccioli di solito sono degli arbusti o
piccoli alberi questo è più grande di
una quercia supera del doppio un palazzo
di due piani Quindi è una pianta
straordinaria anche dal punto di vista
vivaistico perché oltretutto non fa
neanche i Polloni alla base quindi anche
per la coltivazione del nocciolo Questa
pianta è molto importante
altri esemplari che abbiamo nel nostro
territorio nella nostra regione il che
ha pensato un castagno osteria che si
trova sull'Appennino bolognese e così
chiamato perché cavo all'interno è
possibile ospitare fino a 6-7 persone in
una panca che è tutto attorno al tronco
col tavolino centrale quindi dove
seguiamo osterie per questo perché di
solito le persone lì dentro ci andavano
a bere l'altro albero anche questo è
importante se non monumentale Perché i
patriarchi non sono sempre dei monumenti
possono essere anche piante magari di
piccola taglia ma con una genetica Una
storia incredibile viene da Casola
Valsenio Il paese dei frutti di meticati
e i paesi delle Erbe bene Questa pianta
e non la chiamiamo Patriarca Ma
matriarca perché è una pianta femminile
Non solo anche un frutto dimenticato
perché ovviamente è una varietà
sconosciuta
a livello poi Nazionale abbiamo l'olivo
di Lourdes che è il più vecchio del
bacino del Mediterraneo pensate 14 metri
di circonferenza questo addirittura la
pianta patrimonio dell'UNESCO non è solo
il castagno più grande d'Italia ma il
castagno più grande più vecchio del
mondo Questo si trova alle pendici
dell'Etna quindi sulla lava terreni
vulcanici molto adatti per il castagno
tra l'altro
e questo questa è una pianta che è
diventata famosissima alcuni anni fa
nell'ambito di un concorso in cui si
poteva votare a livello europeo l'albero
più bello Si trova in Calabria
Addirittura il paesino di Curinga è
diventato un paese famosissimo
ma non abbiamo censito solo gli alberi
monumentali ci siamo occupati anche dei
patriarchi da frutto questo è la tonda
di Tossignano è un albicocca che ha
rischiato l'iscrizione perché noi
consumatori Vogliamo i frutti grossi
belli uniformi tutto l'anno queste
piccolina ma resiste alle malattie è
straordinarie di sapore e si conserva
molto a lungo qui però c'è una storia
curiosissima un giorno vado a trovare
Tonino Pennabilli e porto con me questo
albicocche e gli dico so che tu ami i
frutti dimenticati Tonino questa ti deve
piacere per forza prova sa già è piccola
non è bellissima ma secondo me è buona
dimmi cosa ne pensi ne prende una la
saggia non dice niente e prende un'altra
l'assaggio Poi a un certo punto chiude
gli occhi poi mi guardi e dice Io ti
ringrazio perché oggi Io ho mangiato
l'infanzia e io dico Tonino Cosa vuol
dire Cosa vuol dire sì perché devi
sapere che io questi frutti questi
Sapori Li ho assaggiati da bambino e non
le ho mai più ritrovati quindi oggi io
sono tornato bambino Questo era Tonino
Guerra
Io spero che dopo queste mie poche
parole anche voi possiate vedere gli
alberi con occhi diversi Anzi potete
fare molto di più potete diventare
volontari attivisti potete abbracciarli
potete fotografarli censirli addirittura
Se volete impegnarvi anche riprodurli
perché non è impossibile ma questo lo
dobbiamo fare perché abbiamo capito che
sono le piante del futuro e lo dobbiamo
fare per i nostri figli e questo è un
patrimonio che appartiene a tutti alla
collettività anche quando sono in aree
private potete addirittura abbracciarli
perché Questi alberi vi caricano di
energia positiva Come mi diceva Tonino
anche lui abbracciava gli alberi Non
solo ma dobbiamo soprattutto far sì che
queste piante arrivino al futuro per i
figli e i figli dei nostri figli e
chiudo con una frase che mi è rimasta in
mente sempre di Tonino e che solo un
grande personaggio poteva pensare e ora
che quando incontriamo un albero diciamo
Buongiorno signor albero
[Applauso]